martine michel stefani bonsoir bonsoir
robot si l'exercice traditionnelle du
bilan de session
évidemment que la pandémie en marquer
cette session parlementaire
l'hélico dans les sièges celle d
épouvantable je fais écouter monsieur
legault parce que en conférence de
presse où lui face à son bilan on lui on
le questionnait bien sûr sur cette
pression des partis d'opposition pour
obtenir une enquête publique et il a
fait son bilan à lui on écoute
durant la session beaucoup de questions
surtout rapport de la protectrice du
citoyen je cacherai pas que j'ai trouvé
ça tue parce que ça m'a rappelé des
moments qui ont été difficile de se
rappeler les les nuits me demander
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de plus donc
ça fait évidemment toujours mal de se re
applique des personnes qui sont décédées
dans la première vague bon j'ai pris je
continue de prendre ma part de
responsabilité dans ce qui s'est
passé
et il explique martine ensuite qu'il a
déjà expliqué plusieurs fois qu'ils
auraient dû augmenter le salaire des
préposés mais que tous ceux qui disent
qu'on aurait pu au mois de mars à voir
ce type au clair comme ça et que oui la
colombie britannique mais il a nommé
paris
bostens ailleurs au monde il n'était pas
tout seul dans ce bateau-là martyrs dont
il se défend
d'avoir été aveuglé à lui son groupe de
crise là au début de la crise en fait sa
défense et dire j'ai fait tout ce que je
pouvais faire j'ai mis des mesures en
place je me suis trompé certains
endroits je voulais pas juger rim je me
suis retourné de bord et g j'ai trouvé
des gens pour aller prêter main forte
dans les 6 h et celle des en fait c'est
un peu ça qui est dit est dit et il ya
même d'une période de questions là cette
semaine à l'impossible nul n'est tenu
alors c'est un peu la
perception qu'il a de sa gestion de la
pandémie c'est que peu été parfait mais
il fait s'il dit que fait ce qu'ils
pouvaient et ça colle ça marche quand
même assez bien et les partis
d'opposition je pas certain qu'ils ont
vraiment semer le doute sur la façon
dont monsieur legault a géré la pandémie
surtout les premières vagues et on a
vraiment l'impression qu'ils avaient de
stefanik lui a l'impression qu'une fois
que le rapport de la coroner va être
déposé au printemps que les québécois
ils réclameront pas tellement une autre
commission denquête surtout ça passe ça
va être loin michel qu'en pensez vous ah
ouais je convaincu que monsieur legault
pense sincèrement qu'il n'y a pas besoin
d'en déclencher il a probablement raison
d'une par contre quand il dit j'ai fait
tout mon possible compte tenu des
renseignements que j'avais la population
le crois je pense à elle a bien vu que
eu des erreurs qui ont été commises mais
d'autres pas du tout de la bonne volonté
monsieur legault et d'autre part parce
qu'on fait beaucoup la comparaison avec
ce qui s'est produit à l'époque quand
jean charest était premier ministre et
qui avait dû céder aux pressions pour
déclencher une enquête sur la corruption
dans l'industrie de la construction et
les liens avec le financement des partis
politiques mais là on n'est pas du tout
dans la même situation monsieur charest
souvenez-vous est à son troisième mandat
il était déjà très impopulaire monsieur
legault est pas là dedans du tout il est
très populaire et il ne sent pas la
pression savez nous couvrons l'assemblée
nationale on a l'impression lequel la
montre autour du salon bleu mais
honnêtement ça perd cols blancs accès à
l'extérieur de l'assemblée nationale des
gens sont pas à cracher le comme ça tous
les jours de sorte que
l'impression générale qu'ils ont laissé
à sa seule t il ça a été mal gérée bien
sûr que de façon générale la pandémie
s'est passé des hommes le moins mal
qu'elle pouvait et à ce moment là je
pense que monsieur legault un rapport à
se poser très longtemps la question ce
que je fais
une enquête ou non il y en a besoin et
ses fans et c'est ça il donne vraiment
l'impression d'être persuadé que dans
l'opinion publique québécoise
je désire d'une enquête publique une
autre n'est pas n'est pas très présent
mais c'est vrai que j'ai l'impression
que les québécois se disent qu'il ya
quand même fait tout ce qu'ils pouvaient
quand tu es quand il s'est retrouvé dans
une situation où personne aurait avec
plan de match laissait en personne
n'était préparé donc oui d'accord et
puis c'est pas parce que le deux tiers
des québécois sont satisfaits de manière
globale de la gestion de la cac en ce
moment c'est quand même très élevé par
contre il ya seulement le tiers des
québécois qui sont satisfaits de la
gestion la pandémie dans les ch et celle
des donc cet aspect là ça devient un peu
une faille dans l'armure beaucoup en
quartiers c'est déjà beaucoup de tiers
compte tenu de ce qui est arrivé mais
bon c'est sûr alors donc on voit que les
partis d'opposition semblent bien
qu'hier il ya une faiblesse de ce côté
là et c'est pour ça qu'ils continuent de
taper sur le clou mais en même temps je
suis assez d'accord avec avec michel la
cac et aytré et très fermé ne veulent
pas faire une commission parce que selon
eux ben ça va m et tout le système de
santé sur pause pendant un longue
période parce que ça va demander
énormément d'informations donc ils
veulent pas se lancer là dedans mais
quand même je pense que les gens qui
sont décédés par milliers on leur doit
ça quand même de faire la lumière
oui il ya des enquêtes en ce moment
qu'ils ont lieu mais on met les
projecteurs à gauche à droite ça serait
peut-être le simple d'ouvrir les
lumières au complet d'abord d'être
certain qu'ils aient resporton nom très
bien je vous fait écouter un autre
extrait de monsieur legault il a
beaucoup vanté le bilan économique du
québec la croissance va bien le taux de
chômage historiquement bornes et en fait
on fait meilleur mieux que les ontariens
que
quand même les américains alors on lui a
demandé un journaliste votre bon coup
votre mauvais coup écoutez bien mauvais
coup ça va m'amener à l'autre sujet
n'est que le contrat qui lie un club
pour moi c'est est important d'avoir
réussi à signer ce contrat c'est un bon
ou mauvais coups bas peut-être que je me
choque trop vite qu'en cas de gale
nadeau-dubois 10 des faussetés faudrait
que j'accepte qui continue de 10 puis
décret des faussetés
ça a été un désert qu'on a beaucoup
entendu depuis
septembre cette nouvelle dynamique entre
q s et la caq martin ça s'est imposé
dans notre jeu de politique ouais il ya
plusieurs raisons à cela d'abord c'est
sûr qu'ils sont très polarisée trek en
paix mais monsieur legault n'a rien à
perdre à débattre directement avec
gabriel nadeau dubois en faire son
principal adversaire la caq c'est une
coalition et il faut savoir qu'à peu
près 25 30% de son au vote qui vient du
parti libéral et ce sont des libéraux
qui veut probablement ne voterai jamais
pour un parti souverainiste alors il
veut protéger ce vote là et plutôt que
de débattre avec dominique anglade et
d'ailleurs ça dérange les libéraux
qu'ils aient choisi gabriel soit parce
qu'ils aimeraient bien récupérer ce vote
là alors ça je pense que c'est un des
aspects qui qui qui justifie pourquoi
monsieur legault cible gabriel nadeau
dubois et l'autre c'est une question de
personnalité monsieur legault m
ils viennent la génération c'est plus
difficile de débattre avec les femmes
monsieur charest était comme ça il ya eu
plus de difficultés vécues pauline
marois il aimait pas tellement ça et
d'ailleurs quand c'était manon massé qui
étaient là ils l'auraient jamais traité
doit qui s'il le faisait s'est passé pas
toujours très bien là c'est pareil c'est
perçu comme si il y attaquent une femme
s'était pas bien perçu alors là ils sont
un peu sur la même page tous les deux
puis l'a dit aujourd'hui les mâles
avaient un petit les manceaux je lui ai
dit les choses pas vrai sur les
éducatrices puis ça m'énerve ça vient me
chercher d'abord les critiques viennent
le chercher peut-être davantage qu'en
début de saison mais je vous fais
michel et ses fans et avant de vous
donner la parole aux faire écouter
l'origine de cette nouvelle dynamique
qui script est en partie par le bureau
du premier est peut-être pas totalement
on verra l'origine c'est la fameuse
accusations du work puis aujourd'hui
réaction de nadeau dubois
depuis quelques jours le premier
ministre a su courber à l'un de ses
pires défauts s'est mis à faire sa
meilleure imitation de maurice duplessis
il s'est autoproclamé père de la nation
québécoise
maurice duplessis
j'avais beaucoup de défauts mais il
défend des sa nation n'était pas un rock
comme le chef de québec solidaire
c'est payant politiquement de se faire
traiter de walk par le premier ministre
je pense qu'on dérange françois legault
parce que nos priorités sont ses
faiblesses en un premier indice qui se
prétend proche du monde mais qui
envisage de donner des millions un
milliardaire pour une demi équipe de
baseball alors que des enfants qui ont
même pas de gymnase pour leurs cours
d'éducation physique à l'école
moi je pense que quand on expose cette
contradiction contradictions là françois
legault se fâche c'est la preuve qu'on
pose les bonnes questions
c'est rare que nadeau dubois qu'on pose
une question il prend quelques secondes
celle là peut déstabiliser mais y est
tellement habile devant les journalistes
et les caméras michel david je vous pose
est-ce que effectivement la question
était bonne ça lui donne de l'air on le
voit pas dans les sondages ou marquer
encore mais ça lui donne de l'air que le
premier ministre est intéressant à
l'huile
convaincu que monsieur nadeau dubois est
ravie de desserts considéré comme le
principal adversaire de monsieur legault
et c'est vraiment naturel dans les deux
cols écoutez le
q est-ce et gabriel nadeau dubois c'est
vraiment l'antithèse du nationalisme
conservateur identitaire
la salle est identitaire d'y jouer chi
chi chi le fondement même du discours de
monsieur legault alors et dans les deux
cas ce sont des adversaires idéaux l'un
pour notre
pendant des années c'était les libéraux
et le pq parce qu'il y avait
fondamentalement la question
constitutionnelle qui était au coeur du
débat là c'est pas ça c'est l'identité
le multiculturalisme contre le
québec comment dire de souche
et dans les deux cas ils
enlèvent tout l'air à l'aise à leurs
adversaires de chaque côté alors il
s'entend très bien pour pour se chicaner
l'avez vous trouvée à bichkek et
secondes puis stéphanie ensuite dans
cette session parlementaire nadeau
dubois ces attaques ces lignes j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup il y apprit écoutez il
ya appris extrêmement rapidement madame
ans et était et est sympa c'est que les
gens
comment dire étaient reconnaissants de
sa sincérité de son sens son souci de la
justice sociale mais personne
n'imaginait vraiment comme première
ministre le demain il ya un gros écart
entre les deux mais quand on pose la
question qui voyez vous comme premier
ministre le premier dame ans et c'est
monsieur me suis le mot mais le deuxième
c'est ce gabriel nadeau-dubois même ses
intentions de vote sont inférieures à
celles du parti libéral ni considéré
comme une personnalité
personnalité forte qui est très
polarisantes mai mais qu'on peut pas
ignorer oui ses fans et vos impressions
sur québec solidaire gavray
nadeau-dubois
japon même sens selon gabriel
nadeau-dubois été très habile eagle dont
d'arrivée avec la bonne question on se
souvient juste avant que le premier
ministre françois legault pour la ville
il ya posé une question il réussit à lui
faire admettre que le troisième ligne
s'étaient pas en ligne avec les
objectifs 20h09 du gouvernement et le
social de 5000 premier ministre dans
mois dans une situation plutôt embêtant
que la lui qui s'en allait parler
d'environnement donc il ya vraiment un
talent pour poser les bonnes questions
et puis je dirais aussi que ça fait
ressortir peut-être un peu côté arrogant
de la carte clan ce moment parce que le
parti est tellement fort tellement
puissant que j'ai l'impression aussi
s'est habitué à gouverner sans
opposition avec la pandémie est là ils
ont comme oublier que will l'opposition
en droit de poser des questions
légitimes et on a le droit aussi de quoi
être d'accord avec ce que avec ce que la
cac pour les temps les valeurs
québécoises on peut on peut être hu et
être quand même un québécois ce qu'est
ce que monsieur leubou semblait
ne pas vouloir admettre mais quand il
comptait donner sa définition du web
c'est une personne qui nous nous empêche
de protéger la nation québécoise va le
je pense qu'il ya un peu de dérives mais
puis cadrait quand il dit que gabriel
nadeau dubois dit des mensonges je pense
que cette semaine ont eu un exemple que
c'était plutôt c'était plutôt le premier
ministre qui était dans un flou
artistique un peu douteux quand il a
commencé à parler du baseball en réponse
à une question justement du chef
solidaire
dit qu'il mettrait pas un sou de
l'argent des contribuables attendent
ensuite quand on le cuisine et un peu
plus au lieu de dire que finalement oui
ce serait pour des subventions à coût
nul pour le contribuable
mallet plutôt commencé à s'attaquer au
langage de gabriel nadeau-dubois disant
que c'était pas dit non moins chef de
parti la boîte s'était colorisée
oui oui c'est que dans le son pur pour
monsieur legault y est pas dangereux
gabriel nadeau dubois dans la mesure où
il sait très bien que les les fondements
de q est-ce là
la nationalisation des moyens de
production la négation de l'économie de
marché
les québécois sont pas là dedans jamais
ils vont embarquer en tout cas pour
l'avenir prévisible et ça monsieur le
nom de ses très bien la parlement madame
en anglais elle et martine elle sonnait
sortir du congrès de dossiers épineux
mais la cherche de l'air cherche de
l'air ouais ben même madame anglade
quand même c'est assez spectaculaire la
session qui est là qu'elle a passée elle
a subi des pressions à l'intérieur à
l'extérieur les couteaux ont volé de
tous les côtés elle un caucus qui est à
peu près ingérable c'est une passoire un
gros trou elle a réussi à avoir
suffisamment d'appuis pour passer à
travers son congrès mais là c'est tout
un virage laquelle qu'elle a imposées à
son parti elle est pas loin de québec
solidaire d'ailleurs québec solidaire la
regarde du côté de l'oeil pour moi
d'aller un peu plus vers le sang ben
c'est ça alors il centre croise alors
dominique anglade est en selle pour 2022
mais c'est très difficile pour elle de
est d'ailleurs réputée elle elle est
confinée à l'indifférence monsieur
legault ne la regarde pas alors en
politique quand tu génères
l'indifférence ce ordinaire bon mais le
temps et là on verra michel le pq on a
on l'a dit
paul st pierre plamondon dans tout ça
il n'est pas allé pour vous étiez
d'accord des hommes celle qui arrive pas
à longueuil mais bref
c'est pas facile quoi c'est pas facile
c'est pas facile un peu comme mame adama
gladio réussi à régler le printemps
jusqu'à l'élection les problèmes qui est
de leadership au sein de son parti à
personne ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre
qui pensent à changer de chef l'a 10
mois de l'élection mais dans les deux
cas ils ont parlé juive à la job
où il ya exactement mais dans les deux
cas ils ont pas je pense réussi la
reconnexion avec l'électorat c'est ça
qui est qui plus important lyon régler
leur parti mais leurs problèmes de
partie mais tous les deux il ya personne
qui s'est rapproché de l'électorat
québécois francophones
alors le problème et
du parti pour régler les problèmes du
chef oui mais pour ce qui est de ce
parti on est toujours au même point il
monsieur legault a dit aujourd'hui mais
les sondages parce qu'il veut pas
envoyer ses troupes l'idée que c'est
réglé ça va être facile il dit les
sondages vont se resserrer dans les
prochains mois merci d'être venu parce
que hier on a évidemment plus le temps
de parler de tout ça merci d'être venu
bonne fin de semaine jette libre et
libérée au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh